do you guys reckon you could survive the
zombie apocalypse no
although maybe they've got ubereats
still going if not
what's the point what's the point it is
but he's also a zombie yeah
like do you want survivors on the
apocalypse i don't know i don't know it
depends where you are right like if
you're in an area that's just like
you're the only one remaining ever like
there's just zombies [ __ ] clawing at
your apartment or whatever then it's
just like
yeah just at that point i'm just like
okay well
the world's [ __ ] anyway you know
whatever i mean i don't
i don't know i feel like a zombie
apocalypse wouldn't be that hard to
survive that's what i'm saying like
that's that's my biggest like unless it
depends on the type of zombie right
because if you're talking about like the
traditional really slow [ __ ] zombie
that [ __ ] walks
like how did this become an apocalypse
in the first place how are people this
incompetent that this became an actual
apocalypse it's because in all those
movies they're just like no don't come
here while they're standing still all
right like no
if it's 28 days later all right now now
now i get how could it out yeah if we're
like talking like cod zombies then it's
like yeah i'm [ __ ] but i feel like you
know how like some of the movies they
managed to make like villages that are
like really tall walls and anki
i feel like that's that would be if i've
learned anything from dead rising it's
just just stay them all
yeah yeah hit them with uh with a phone
phone back
yeah combined with
hit him with the
bench put the machine guns on the
wheelchair yeah and drive the wheelchair
i i feel like you know i feel like if a
zombie apocalypse ever did happen that's
the one place where you know being in
america would be a massive [ __ ]
advantage because you think about how
easy it is to gain access to weapons
here in japan until the zombies learn
about those and they're like
we could use this too
oh i thought you were gonna be like
cause you can just go to like north
dakota and there's no one there
oh that's true that's that escape
[Laughter]
i mean that's that's the one place where
if you have a gun it would be like very
very useful like yeah but i mean you're
assuming guns will stop zombies exactly
that's true that is true because like
games have led us to believe that it's
like you want to kill a zombie just get
good at headshots but it's like
realistically will it actually kill how
much ammo can you really get a hold of
you know resident evil got one thing
right it'd be [ __ ] annoying to be
like conserving your ammo with this [ __ ]
actually like i would be that guy i
would be that guy would you have you
don't shoot it guy's like i'm sorry i
got four bullets
like i wouldn't be like a zombie could
be right in front of me and i'd be like
searching for like an axe or something
be like i didn't shoot a zombie i don't
know i don't need to shoot a zombie you
know maybe i'll need this ammo for like
the boss battle whatever that guitar
collection boys are winning that's for
sure i would do anything i could even if
i had a gun to not use a gun just in
case
i'm gonna go back to the safe room
probably
honestly the best thing you could
probably have is just having a medieval
set of armor and wow yeah like like a
sword how the [ __ ] are they going to
bite you yeah you're wearing a full like
chain mail and you've got a big ass long
sword i think you're good yeah
those chats on youtube the ones you're
talking about the
correct sword techniques they're they're
going to be the real winners yeah yeah
that's what i've always like struggled
to
to figure out right like the the video
game logic of yeah just shoot them in
the head and i'll stop them and i'm like
but they're dead already
why would why why would they die like a
normal human being
i mean i don't know yeah it depends how
the zombies function yeah
if it's parasite taking the body yeah
we're talking about fake uh i mean fake
science now it could could you know it
could be it could be any sort of reason
or anything you know if you like if you
have a [ __ ] katana or something and
you just like you know chop their body
into bits then they can't do anything
right even if they're still alive you're
gonna chop someone's body in the video
you know how long that's gonna take
you're gonna be yeah this is a zombie
apocalypse i'm gonna take him out one at
a time you know joe's gonna let him just
sit down and have a breather when he's
done
it's like hold on hold on
joey thinks that katana works like it
does an anime we just like does like the
[ __ ] sword thing and like the zombies
there's zombies in a hundred pieces
that's true
all right you know what guns gone yeah
flamethrower is pretty good right
flamethrower yeah
i mean is a flamethrower an actual good
weapon or is it just like an aesthetic
weapon it's a very good weapon um it's a
waste of money but i mean if you if you
hit someone with it they die but
wouldn't it wouldn't i i know that but
yeah but what are the fuel for a
flamethrower to be more scarce than
boats yeah surely there's more effective
weapons and like it looks cool and it's
affected but surely there's more
efficient weapons i should say that it's
it's like it's like absolutely
inefficient but like if you hit someone
i think with it i think they just
because like the ones that like i think
elon musk style for example yeah that's
basically just like a hairspray with a
lighter yeah yeah i think the original
ones in like world war ii were like they
would actually shoot out oil on fire
yeah because you could see the streams
of liquid yeah so they would land in
here obviously if you get hit with that
that's just gonna like burn of course
but like what i'm trying to say is you
you know you you you have two guys one
person has a flamethrower one person has
a gun i think the person with the gun is
going to win come out of that battle
right yeah but you're not fighting
you're finding a zombie that's true
that's true okay okay i feel like your
your goal is to make it so the zombie
can't move what a weird topic
if you're like
your goal because we don't you don't
know you don't even know if you can kill
it what if the gun doesn't work but what
if what if the zombie doesn't feel the
heat but what if you burn off like his
legs but you could just chop off his
legs as well are you gonna chop off his
legs i don't know are you gonna be
hacking away how long is that gonna take
joey's just living like the anime dream
of like using his katana now i just
wanna be kirito okay
i admit it
if you i just want to come out and
[ __ ] do this
if you do somebody wants to like jewel
with the sword he just burned off his
arms and legs he wouldn't be able to
move it i just want to be guts
what about like chainsaw then yeah
that's pretty pretty i feel that'd be
more geezer probably got that right yeah
yeah yeah also but i wonder
no no no yeah i wonder if like bones
would like clog a chainsaw or do
anything probably not cause i think
trees are stronger than bones i think
are they i don't i don't know but we
don't build houses our bones gone well
that's because we don't farm
we don't really farm birds
we don't have a forest full of bones and
we can farm and build houses
build a house out of bones dude that
sounds [ __ ] badass
that's like a tim burton
that's that's what you can do right in
the zombie apocalypse you collect the
limbs and you just take the bones and
just make a house out of it
there you go problem solved
recycling in the zombie apocalypse
the one thing the zombies can't
penetrate a house full of bones
because they'll be like oh you're just
one of us with a few extra bones
i'm not gonna need that yeah i think in
some countries where you're not allowed
to fill up a gas canister as well i
think it's illegal so you wouldn't be
able to get a stockpile of gas because
it turns into a weapon uh
normally it is when the government is
concerned that you that your population
might be making uh weapons right right
oh okay okay yeah yeah yeah that makes
sense yeah um
so will they carry during a zombie
apocalypse is the question
no true they're not going to be like
step number one you've got to get a
container and number two you're probably
not going to be the first guy at the gas
station that's probably not sure
we've seen it when gas prices when we
hear about gas shortages everyone goes
yeah it's already too late but i guess
that's the first thing you should do in
any apocalypse immediately go to the gas
place and get i don't even have a car
but i'm getting the gas i'm getting
gassy because i know i'm gonna be king
when people want gas
i'm like well i can give you and i have
four tanks in the back okay that's true
i'm like covered in like [ __ ] black
smooth
yeah because i was thinking because like
i feel like part of part of the reason
why it's so hard to get people to take
action over
i don't know like real life apocalypses
that could be happening right now is
because real life apocalypses sound so
[ __ ] boring like
like oh the the the temperature of the
earth slowly changing by a few degrees
every year we need to do the best to
work like like that sounds so boring
like compared to like we're being
invaded by a horde of zombies and only
you can take them on with that warming
is the least sexy apocalypse
everyone likes the zombie thing because
they want they think that they're going
to become the chad who games the system
becomes the king because it's all in
video games right like when have you
heard of a [ __ ] video game where you
have to fight global warming
maybe we need that we can't
eat that yeah
let's be honest right i think in a
zombie apocalypse you're going to die
from another person no not a zombie the
people who made dead rising just need to
make like the heat rising right right
now something like that
you go to prison for 20 years if you
kill someone
and people still do it
in the zombie apocalypse there's not
going to be any punishment people are
going to start killing everyone that's
true that's true everyone's going to be
like oh my god i i that one guy pissed
me off on the train and we didn't find
him yeah i think yeah i feel during a
zombie apocalypse everyone's just gonna
be so on edge that you're probably gonna
get killed by another human being
there's no way anyone would admit to
being bitten like i thought i thought
everyone who didn't admit to being
bitten in a zombie movie was the [ __ ]
but in reality we've been through a
pandemic now that's just like that's
just like most of you the human race at
this point yeah like if you got it like
you also probably have to kill other
people as well yeah of course of course
if you want to get their stuff of course
i'm just saying
it's just a battle royale
if fortnite has told me anything
if uh kill them if that old grandma has
uh a full supply
of water and food i'm sorry
zuma's arrested the zoomers are ready
man four night has trained them
how to kill order off
we live in like japan you the last
person you ever go against in a video
game is like 16 year old asian kids
because they're just insane well we'll
be killed
sure
they're like challenger rank and we're
like
trying to figure out what's going on
they've already built a fortress
they've been perfectly trained by
fortnite and minecraft to build the
perfect fortress
like ironically these kids would have
somewhat of an understanding of basic
survival because of minecraft yeah more
than that
you're actually right
going back to useless skills like i
think i i feel like i should more know
more
survival skills than i do right you
should why why i mean i've seen you guys
you're like please please i've seen you
i've seen you trying to start a fire
with a piece of flint
that's why i feel like i need to learn
more survival skills than i already
would ever get a bunker like a a like
bunker in your hand like a bomb bonker
yeah like a shelter that'd be cool
but yeah but if you like if you're like
traveling a bunch of your work it's
useless
yeah it is but it just it's just cool
you know
i i wouldn't want a bunker
for emergencies i would just want a
bunker because it's just cool to have
like a secret bunker you've seen that
guy on youtube he's building one yeah
yeah yeah
yeah it's
uh if you have a trash can
trash tastes embarrassing
we need land yeah you need the land
we don't have landscape
none of us own land buy the land first
you do whatever the [ __ ] you want with
it yes yeah that's what that's what i'm
gonna do if i ever buy land in the
future here i'm like [ __ ] the house
build a bunker honestly there's just
there's just something about the idea of
building a bunker that just like no
matter how old you are it just feel it
just fulfills like this childhood dream
it's like a tree house it's like it's
kind of like the next level treehouse
right it's kind of like exciting it's
like yeah
yeah it's like it's like a secret base
right yeah just just imagine wait what's
the difference your basement in the
bunker huh a bunk or a basement is just
like an underground like uh i think i
think a bunker is supposed to be like
secured yeah it's supposed to be
you can survive there you know our
basement is just there's tons of
basements in london
it's like it's three stories but they're
not bunkers there's not they're not
bunkers but i thought like three levels
deep which some of these basements are
well when i think of a bike if you're a
three level deep maybe you can like
maybe you can convert that into a bunker
but when i when i think bunker i don't
just think a room you know i think like
a sizeable amount of secret space that's
secure i think like the only way to get
in is through a hatch
you know like that's what i think yeah
yeah yeah right right not like a welcome
to the wall yeah
i really want a basement i just want to
have a basement i want a bunker
no you want a basement did you did you
ever have like a tree house or anything
like that as a kid where are you the
[ __ ] out of treehouse that's what i was
saying
this treehouse was this mythical thing
that some kids talked about but i've
never known a single person my friend
had a tree house yeah because he had a
tree house because there's always that
one kid who's that one dad who's like
never tired after work and actually
wants to do [ __ ] and he actually gets
[ __ ] it was it was the one dad that
worked from home
oh yeah yeah it was the one that worked
from home check out checks also the
construction dance yep
that was my test oh they got [ __ ] down
yeah yeah my friend had a it wasn't like
a but it wasn't like a massive like
[ __ ] simpsons treehouse looking thing
it was literally like enough to maybe
fit like two five-year-olds in like it
was it was very like an adult would not
be able to fit in that like why a tree
house i've always wondered why why why
it feels like you're one with nature
because this is just kind of cool to be
able to like sit comfortably those poor
trees we on a tree yeah we mock it by
taking its own kind and fashioning it
into a house and putting it on top of it
how cruel of us
kind of like building a house out of
bones
a doghouse a doghouse
[Laughter]
made out of bones
if anyone is going to have a house out
of bones it's tim burton
i want to build a bunker now i just want
to build a space right i do want a i do
want a basement let's let's just start
off with a basement did you did you not
have a basement
uh no i've never had no i've never had a
basement sorry uh sorry going back to
another question i'm ignoring your
basement yeah
who which one of us would survive the
longest in a zombie or some kind of
apocalypse do you think and why
i don't know it's a good question
um
i feel
i feel gantt would trust someone to be
betrayed by them i feel you would just
be like i'll be the alpha male and just
go out and immediately just get killed
that's so true you're like out of the
way boys i got this now
i feel like you would come up with like
the perfect plan of how to survive the
zombie apocalypse and they're not
falling i
somehow like overlook something it's
step one
out of confidence or something i feel
like jay wouldn't realize the apocalypse
was going on yeah
the moment i would
[Laughter]
day
busy meditating
i just escaped to my mind palace
yeah i don't know like um i don't feel
like i i feel like we have different
varying degrees of survival instincts
but i don't feel any one of us about
those things is particularly strong
either
i mean i guess we'll like maybe we
should do a survival special i feel the
best way to determine how someone would
survive in a zombie apocalypse is how
they how they play dead rising
because i think
because i feel like people who are just
like i'm just going to [ __ ] pick up
something and charge right into the
crowd other people who would not survive
as long as people like pick up what a
newspaper yeah why would anyone go into
a new show i'm gonna pick up this tennis
ball see how much damage it does to the
zombies
that's the kind of person who would just
be like charged i don't think anyone's
doing that
i don't know like everyone
i don't know what i'm doing in zombie
focus i mean everyone would just cry
like just cry just cry just camp and
like
break down and cry
i mean you just try to stay and stay in
like the same place for as long as
possible i think you'd have to find a
sidekick as soon as possible a
well like sidekick
if you're gonna if you're gonna survive
you need to become the main character
how do you become the main character by
getting a sidekick
right you get a song
you're gonna run around in like the
[ __ ] apocalypse town and be like who
wants to be my sidekick
you know you if you like to survive
conversation pov you're just walking
around you're like all right a zombie is
about to destroy uh about to kill this
uh 10 year old kid yeah you save the kid
you're like all right fine i'll look
after you now you're the main character
yeah but then you have to take care of a
[ __ ] table yeah
because he's only 10 years old so he
doesn't need as much food as a full of
drinks
so
then when you
you can make him go like look out or
something i don't know right so just
bait
you know
i think
like finding a kid and then making him
like do all the tedious tasks
it's probably a good idea but what just
sounds like a parent at that point yeah
well yeah but
but also you won't you won't be you'd
get some tangible benefit
but whereas in real life you know you
don't he just [ __ ] off and
then goes to move to japan